prende tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo un po adrenalinico un po
più del solito perché non sono stato
sulla mia sedia normale sono stato su
una sedia po più pericolante che vedrete
tra poco perché ho fatto un'esperienza
su un si chiama blackshape non mi
intendo di aerei fammi vedere blackshape
sono entrato in ciabatte costume su
questa e roero in ciabatte ed ero col
costume non è proprio l'indicato volare
così ma fa niente perché forse pensava
di esservi aerodinamico lo so non ho
idea ma vale forse cadevo nell'acqua ero
già pronto ma per chi se ne frega
comunque sia godetevi il video io sto
andando in aeroporto mi vedrete
all'inizio mi sono un po spostato perché
mi stavo cagando sotto giustamente mi
dispiace solo per l'audio nell'aereo che
sarà un pochettino fastidioso perché
giustamente si sente il motore però
volete il video è let's roll
[Musica]
si paga l'aero dei flintstones ma no
allora ragazzi
passiamo va bene va bene allora io
lascio il mio canale a nichi non lascio
tutto questo e grazie al mio amico
matteo
[Musica]
è
niente io starò male
[Musica]
praga
il play torta roma
di fatto viene
no e questo è un affronto e questo era
troppo
[Musica]
oddio ex si sia anche quando prendo il
pullman è uguale per non dire così
ma bello proprio di quelli fatti bene i
ragazzi questo era il mio lavoro lo so
ma siamo partiti da grottaglie era al
posto che siamo andati in giro insomma
per tutto tutta quella parte di puglia
meravigliosa vista anche al contrario è
bellissima io vorrei farvi capire la
sensazione difficilissimo spiegando di
quando tutti gira al contrario poi fai
questa cosa
praticamente si senti senti tutta la
gravità sulla tua testa e ti senti tipo
una sottiletta e starebbe è una
bellissima sensazione
quindi spero che gli sia piaciuto
ragazzi come al solito se il video è
piaciuto al 100 commento non vi piace
anche vari social comunista la
descrizione se non sono prestiti chiede
e noi come sempre mai poi ci vediamo ad
un prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]